[Music]
hi this is an interview with jack morris
who is a phd student at cornell in
natural language processing however jack
has a really cool blog and he's written
a piece called the weird and wonderful
world of a.i art which we're gonna
discuss today now as i said jack is a
phd student in nlp but for this blog
post he dove into the world of ai art
which is sprawling currently and we're
going to talk about you know what
happened so far what are the origins of
ai art at least since the deep learning
area what's currently happening with all
the diffusion models and clip
combinations and vq gans and so on and
we'll also discuss a little bit where
it's going in the future this was a
really cool conversation i certainly
learned a lot and i invite you to check
it out throughout the conversation we
have so many points to jump off of and
i'm sure you'll find something that's
interesting to you i'll leave a link to
the blog post down in the description so
if you want to go and read that for
yourself i absolutely invite you to do
so as always please leave a like if you
do let us know what you think in the
comments and thank you everyone who's
sharing out these videos and helping
others find my content that's really
nice thanks a lot i hope you're having
fun bye
hi everyone today i'm here with jack
morris who is a phd student at cornell
and works in a research group on nlp but
also writes about all kinds of things on
his blog among other things an article
that i found really interesting called
the weird and wonderful world of ai art
that is a description a little bit of a
history a little bit of a summary and an
overview and a bit of an outlook as well
over the current state of art in ai
specifically image generation models and
beyond which i found super fascinating
this is a topic that in recent years uh
has picked up there's almost an
improvement every day now in this world
and it's crazy and i thought it'd be a
great opportunity to invite jack here to
talk to us about you know what's going
on how these different things work and
maybe also a bit
why they work and what the what the sort
of accelerators behind that is so jack
welcome very much to the channel
yeah thanks for having me
um how did you we we were talking just a
little bit before we started recording
about this how did you how did you even
get into this you you researcher in nlp
which has also seen its own revolution
over the last few years how does someone
like you end up in the world of of ai
art in the world of
diffusion and clip and whatnot
yeah
this is a really interesting research
area because
uh it's it's super new so
most of all the developments are
happening online
and uh it's very distributed in the
sense that i think like a lot of the
a lot of the major participants aren't
affiliated with like big companies or
universities and so the way i kind of
got involved was well really just seeing
the art online like specifically for me
on twitter just seeing like some of
these images that are generated this
this one on the screen is a pretty good
example
um
that
just really challenged my beliefs of
like what what neural networks could do
like um i if you had shown me this a
year or two ago i probably wouldn't have
believed that it was generated by a
neural network i mean there there is
some really cool computer generated art
like procedural generated stuff and
i mean there are all sorts of techniques
like that but
in terms of just abstract open-ended
image generation like these are just
qualitatively i think a lot a lot more
interesting than the things that that
i'd seen before and so anyways i i kind
of went down this rabbit hole over this
past winter of just
looking at the art that a lot of artists
were producing and trying to track down
the techniques that they were using it
was actually pretty hard um like there's
there's this sort of
like commodity in the form of collab
notebooks that people are sharing on
twitter and there's a there are a couple
hubs like a few people are are producing
maybe like the most popular the most
interesting ones and then the collab
notebooks get get forked and there's
various versions of them and they're all
changing different things and using
different versions of the techniques but
i think i was able to sort of identify
like what the most important things were
and uh
what what most people were using but it
took a while um
but anyways to answer your question i
guess i just saw the art on twitter and
i thought it was really cool
is is very interesting and you
throughout the whole article you make a
point that you have
maybe a hypothesis of what spurred these
things and that would be i if i
represent this correctly multimodal
models uh the the advent of things like
dolly and clip combining different
modalities together uh really gives an
artist control over things and this kind
of brings us a step back into how things
were first done initially
these pictures that you have on here i
remember fondly from my early days in
deep learning which was the sort of yeah
deep dream on the left or style transfer
in the middle this was the like this was
the non plus deep dream was like that
thing all right just like oh wow like
this is this is it's trippy it's cool
and it kind of gives you an insight into
what neural networks are doing but
things have come a long way right um can
you i don't know when you look at the
history of all of these things what
what's the
big arch
well uh do you want to just go through
these three pictures really sure yeah
so so deep dream is is the thing on the
left um which is i i think based on the
idea of finding the input that
maximizes some certain like internal
thing in the neural network like in this
case in that picture i imagine it was
something like
like the dog class and in this case i'm
really not sure what's going on it's
always the dark class right an image
imagenet it's like it's it's dog
everywhere um right
yeah yeah you could you could excite
like a class you could excite some
internal thing
um yeah i remember
people were very excited about this yeah
it's a cool idea like normally uh at
least a lot of the supervised learning
people do we we look at the gradients of
the parameters with respect to the input
but
deep dream is based on the gradient of
the the input right and actually instead
of changing the parameters of the model
changing changing the input to maximize
something which is which is a cool idea
in and of itself
yeah it is uh i mean it is a akin to an
adversarial example in some way although
i think this is heavily regularized
because adversarial examples usually you
don't necessarily see them or they give
you some high frequency artifacts and
this
uh this is very very different and
people
you know if if we talk about art uh
would this
already classify as
art like you know what's
what what would an artist make of
something like deep dream
yeah that's a that's a philosophical
question i'm not sure i'm qualified to
answer that one but uh some of the
some of the pieces produced with deep
dream are really interesting and
they definitely fall under the realm of
sort of like psychedelic
uh like trippy artwork but uh some of
them are are really cool
the the next thing the next iteration
that you have right here are is style
transfer
networks can you just briefly maybe
someone hasn't heard of that how does it
how does style transfer to how does it
work on a very basic level
um yeah yeah it works by uh
just exploiting the properties of
convolutional neural networks to apply
sort of like the texture from one image
to the content of another and so this
case the content of the image would be
like the mona lisa
and in the middle one
that the style definitely comes from
some van gogh starry night type of
impressionist painting yeah
and and those are really interesting too
i i think there are a bunch of apps that
came out that are basically just like
letting you do style transfer through an
app on your phone like input two images
and it'll copy the style from one onto
the content of another yes
and and this was
i mean it's still
it's still it is definitely more
controllable let's say than the deep
dream one but it gives you
much more predictable results i think
this is more akin to
how i would describe like photoshop or
something right it's not really you're
producing something it's you're taking
something and then you're kind of
changing it its properties a little bit
you can really imagine like in photoshop
i'd have like a fongo filter and i just
put it up and it produces something like
this
yeah yeah um well first of all i think
that's a that's a useful distinction
this is more like an
image editing technique or at least it
takes two images as an input and outputs
one image and a lot of the other things
we're looking at take
take nothing as an input and output an
image
or uh in in the case of the stuff we'll
get to take text as an input and output
an image
so this is sort of like a stylistic
combination of two images and you can
only do it with neural network um i i
think photoshop specifically you
mentioned has this
new well they adobe's doing all these
cool things with
of course this type of research
and the newest photoshops have these
like neural filters which are
which is a new feature that includes
a bunch of different things you can
apply to images that are based on neural
networks and i think one of the neural
filters is is using style transfer like
basically it's built into photoshop now
which is cool yeah
well i mean yeah it's excellent i would
do the same if i if i were them right
they
they um i think
the the adobe suite is like
insane powerhouse like how much work
went into that um
so then the advent of gans came
and i remember gans fondly as well
because that's when i started going to
conferences and every single track on
every single room and every single
workshop was about gans like you could
not it is worse than transformers today
it was just everywhere and uh at
initially it wasn't super duper hype but
then they got good and here we see some
some this person does not exist which is
a very famous website and i think
there's been everything from this shoe
does not exist to
this i don't know
whatever does not exist um
but however again these are these are
now free form produced images right but
they're very realistic
that is so we're at the other end of the
spectrum we are not modifying an
existing image but we producing
something out of nothing
yet
it they're very much along a data set
yeah so this this would be an example of
one of the things that takes nothing as
an input and just produces an image as
the output
and that's probably
like at least one of the reasons why
cans were so hyped is just because like
these images are so
realistic it's it's somewhat terrifying
i've i've used this as an example to
show my friends that
aren't as like up to date in ai research
and just just to scare them a little bit
and show them like the kinds of things
that could be done
and this is probably one of the most
well-known examples i think of like what
neural networks can can actually do
right now is produce these really
realistic human looking images of people
that
i i think they're sort of like just
interpolated versions of all the faces
in the in the training data but there's
so many faces in the training data that
it it just forms like a totally new face
i i don't think you could like map it
back to any individual person yeah and
it's usually usually at the ears you can
recognize although here one is hidden
but usually kind of the ears would be uh
would be kind of different the left and
right one enough for for uh you to
recognize that there's something wrong
but they are uncannily realistic usually
these gan produced images so this would
be this would be a stylegan v2 probably
um
and maybe for someone who doesn't know
at all how gans work there are two
networks one is trying to produce images
one is trying to distinguish whether or
not a given image is real or fake and
these two they essentially play a game
and they become better uh they sort of
level each other up until the the one
that's generating images gets really
good at
confusing the other one and
in order to do that it needs to produce
realistic images this is yeah and the
gans would make will make their
appearance later on when we talk about
things like vqgan and so on but these
were the first iterations of really
realistic
realistic producing images and you have
this interesting thing here art breeder
which i was kind of aware but there is a
story behind this and tick tock so what
what's that about
oh well um wait can we can we stay on
the gans for a second so
um
it's not it's not immediately obvious i
think why
they work so well like there are other
models that
can generate random images and
and some of them work well too um but
gans not only have that sort of cool
explanation of being the result of two
models competing with it with each other
um well
we can be specific too this is
if they're gan generated these are the
outputs of the generator network of
those two networks
and
there are other networks that generate
images but gans just tend to do it like
really really well so the reason why i
include them here is because they
basically are the state of the art for
generating realistic images
um
so yeah so
the on to art breeder um
i i think there's just a there's a
famous tik tok that that showed
generating faces using art breeder um
which is a another example of ai sort of
like making its way into the mainstream
with all this stuff
i included it because um
like you mentioned i think the the main
thesis of my article
is that
by training these multimodal models we
can
generate art that's like specific to a
level that we were never able to do
before
and so starting with gans they they
start
somewhere random like they just start
with this random initialization that's a
vector of floating point numbers and you
have no idea what it means so you have
no idea how to like
position it in such a way that it's that
it's useful
and so as an artist um you could
probably do two things
one you could accept your fate the fact
that you have no control over the
initialization and just sort of like
try to produce things that are that are
cool like either by brute force just
generating a lot of images or by like
looking at the output of the gan and
maybe like editing it yourself like
maybe using it for inspiration or a
starting point for some artwork
but
actually like making changes to the
artwork yourself and the second thing
you could do is maybe some kind of
search like if you
if you start with multiple
initializations you could
examine them all and determine which one
maybe has the most value to you or seems
the most promising and then do some kind
of like recombination of the most
interesting initializations kind of like
a binary search through the latent space
of the gan
and this is this is basically how our
breeder works instead of just generating
one image and trying to edit it or just
generating a bunch of images and
choosing the best one
our breeder
art breeder has this iterative process
where you generate like a few images and
you choose the one that you think is
best and then
generate more images based on that
initial image and you go through this
process step by step in order to sort of
like zero in on something that you find
interesting
and and this is probably better but it's
probably still not the best way to like
coax interesting results out of games
um
there has been like
a lot of research into making gans more
controllable uh
so people people trying to figure out
you know how can you control the latent
space but we're still not there i agree
with you uh it is quite hard to make
these things actually to control these
things and steer these things um i just
wanna so a few things to note right here
this is the original paper uh just for
people who are unaware how far we've
come in this domain uh the first outputs
of these things they looked they looked
like uh like this so so
and these were faces that were totally
aligned uh so all the eyes are in the
same place all the noses are in the same
place and still that was the output uh
even worse if you look at sort of the
image data sets it was it was very good
at the time but it was not um as you can
see
it was there's there
these
the uh the progress is immense
uh the other thing for art breeder uh i
think
uh just also you people may not know
it's
uh based on this idea called pick
breeder i don't actually know if this is
the original site um
the original site is by is by
uh certainly ken stanley was part of it
where they had also these things
creating pictures and these were not
neural networks these were i mean they
were they had a latent space but the
latent space was quite lower dimensional
and it's kind of a function
a
function using trigonometric
uh overlapping functions that produces
these images and then also pig people
can sort of recombine images so it's
really cool to see that this comes to
the world of neural networks because pig
breeder itself has been around for a
long time
um and yeah there's there's you said
there's a famous tick tock on on how
these things are made
yeah there's there's a link if you want
to pull it up oh is there
let's check it out there's a link to
reddit um
and
one tic
once tick-tock ah once tick-tock
discovered it okay so people
people making tick-tock about how they
art breed
i guess that's one way to go viral
um
so yeah you had you had a you had you
have this intermediate post here about
the problem with pre-clip art and
essentially uh
lacking control that's the the big deal
right
the artists can maybe influence stuff a
little bit but not too much especially
if they're not an expert in neural
networks they have no
clue except to try it out
yeah uh and you mentioned that
there's been a lot of efforts to make
gans like controllable and in some way
or another and i think uh
that there's some success to that like
there i know there are some interfaces
where you can like generate faces and
adjust you know the thickness of the
eyebrows and the the distance between
the eyes and things like that
but if if we just try and think about
this from from first principles i mean
if
what kind of images are we trying to
generate i think the the goal would be
just some kind of like open-ended
thing where the model knows about the
world and can generate pictures of
whatever you want
and given that what what would the ux
look like like in the case of faces
maybe they can design this this panel
that has knobs and sliders and things
where you can readjust how the face
looks but that doesn't apply
to everything in the whole world um so
at least one guess is just by typing
stuff in i think texas is a really good
user interface for this
um you can basically be as specific as
possible but you can you can mention
anything and so we come to this idea
where we have like a text box and you
type in the text box what you want to
see and the model like generates an
image from that
and so everything we're going to talk
about after here is some kind of
like take on on that paradigm
essentially
there is yeah there is the the paradigm
of inputting text and the paradigm of
actor critic essentially an actor critic
framework where usually the way that
these things work is that you'd have one
model that produces stuff
which could be again but could also be
other image producing models and then a
critic that judges whether it's good or
not now interestingly that it's kind of
the same setup as the gan itself right
but the critic right here is going to be
clip or any sort of multi-modal model
where we can control what it does
via text
and i find it interesting and instead of
uh instead of updating the parameters of
the model like we would
with the gan we're going back to the
thing we discussed before where we're
updating the actual input itself yes
exactly yeah it's kind of like it's sort
of a deep dream gan combination and
i guess for that we have to talk a
little bit about clip now most people
have probably heard of clip but clip is
essentially a model that takes a piece
of text and an image and it tells you
how well they go together uh how well
the piece of text describes the image
essentially now what we can do is we can
simply keep the piece of text fixed and
back propagate through the input
in order to
figure out the gradient
of whatever the input currently is with
respect to that text which essentially
means how do we need to change the image
in order to make it more compatible to a
piece of text
and we hope that if we walk that path
uh many many steps then we'll arrive at
an image that fits to the text very well
right
and
the reason that we need sort of an
artist in front of it which is also
interesting is because if we were to do
this just starting from random pixels
and then just optimize the pixels the
way neural networks work is we would
probably get something quite
although i've seen some people do it
directly but we'd probably get a lot of
high frequency noise and artifacts and
so on
and
having a gan in front of it is almost a
bit like a regularization or a
constraint to
[Music]
to make the outputs more
let's say believable
um
yeah but i agree that's that's how it
could work in principle it's just it's
more an artifact of just the tools we
have now is that clip is is trained to
do this sort of like image caption
appraisal
but it's not necessarily
it doesn't have the right parameters to
generate images and and people try but
it's just not that good because of how
it's trained but we do have things that
are really good at generating images
like all the various scans
and so the artist critic idea is to just
sort of like couple them together and
because the whole thing is
differentiable you can use the critic to
figure out like how good is the art and
then back propagate through the critic
and through the artist back to the
input itself and edit the input to
maximize the output of the critic
i find it very interesting that now
obviously you go you go through a bit
later uh through the
initial successes of this model um clip
plus clip plus
uh big gan for example where we do
exactly that here for example is a
prompt that is
i don't even know it's like a city i
don't know what the prompt was but this
picture was very famous because it kind
of showed that wow you can actually do
something i find it interesting though
that the origin story simply came from
the fact that open ai released this
model this blog post here about a model
called dali
which would actually do it you it was
trained to directly produce an image
given a piece of text
there was no no iterative process no
walking gradients nothing it was just
input a piece of text and out comes an
image it was insane like the blog post
was insane right the avocado chair or
hear that teapot in the shape of an
avocado
these are
insane yet openly i just didn't publish
the model because
i don't know they're usually their their
go-to line is that it's too dangerous or
something um
and
had open ai released this model
all of the
i i think all of the things that we see
in the rest of the blog post would have
never happened i'm pretty convinced
because
we just people were just kind of stoked
that we only have the clip model we
didn't have the dahle model so how can
we like get around this
oh yeah i absolutely agree although i i
feel it may have been somewhat
inevitable like it's not that
either dolly or clip was any sort of
major technical breakthrough but i mean
there's a lot of engineering required
and just a lot of
monetary resources required to train the
models
but i i don't know how long it would
have been before another multimodal
model was released that was that was
equally good
um but we can we can talk about dali for
a second i know you said you me you made
a video about it before
um
people people do produce art with dali
and i think some people have a
preference for it
um it it's basically trained like a
language model is that right just with
text and then pixels yeah essentially so
here is yeah here is you have a picture
of rue daly which is uh
trained uh on the russian language
picture combinations but
yeah people use this and it
i feel it it uh it is a bit more
representative of maybe the data set
that you put in in that it gives a bit
more realistic
pictures
yeah and i think um
as an artifact of training it like a
language model
dolly tends to produce like much more
abstract pictures like it's sort of
hedging between a bunch of different
pictures that could satisfy the caption
instead of what gans do which is just
sort of like picking one thing and doing
it as
as best as it can you know
and so
it it tends to be very different i think
in the in the glide paper which we'll
talk about later they they compare the
output of
this glide system to dolly and they they
just say like dolly tends to produce
much more abstract images i think maybe
80 or 90 percent of the time as rated by
humans i see and also the
the shutter stock um
the
shutter stock water marks are pretty
pretty cool that's a data set thing yeah
this is if anyone's listening to this
and wants to try it out the the best
open source model right now
is this rue dolly i think
at least in in best open source model
that does the same thing as dolly and
they have and so there's a playground
where you can try it out right yeah but
but it is it's trained on like russian
data so the playground is like you you
import a translation model and then you
type
if you're speaking english or whatever
you have to translate the prompt into
russian yep so that probably makes it
even more uh abstract
um yeah pretty pretty cool uh there's
also there there are other really like
true let's say open source um efforts to
replicate this uh one is this
lyon 400m data set which is a data set
of image text pairs because uh none of
these
other models really release their data
set although i do believe it's not
directly by a luther as you have right
here i don't know how much they are
affiliated but um
it is fully open source yeah
uh and there's also there's
um there's also a project called i think
mini dolly
that attempts to to do dolly in less
scale and i think they're also yeah
people who are really trying to to
replicate this that's pretty cool
yeah i i link to minnie dully somewhere
i think they're they're scaling it up
too so eventually it'll be a large mini
deli
um and and here with with the advent of
this with the advent of yeah what was
called the big sleep um
which is this i don't even know if is
this an illusion to too deep dream uh
this big come from big gan i don't i
don't know but
here we really start this advent of what
you described of collab notebooks being
passed around right and sort of this
this art taking off really on twitter
and through twitter and not anymore
through
because all the other things there they
were kind of conceived in research
papers and then people adapted it to
things and here
we entered the realm of people doing
just collabs and and just kind of
sharing them around right
yeah yeah i think this month
specifically was a really interesting
time like uh dolly was an open source
but clip was
and you can you can uh kind of track
how the lineage of all this through
through the tweets like clip was
released and there there were people
that were already working on using deep
learning to generate art and some of
those people did things like
just the most basic thing the the deep
dream thing trying to optimize the
picture that goes with a certain
a certain caption
and the results are like
really
like really bad looking like um but they
but they're
they're promising like you would see
sort of like outlines of things or like
little words that were represented
representative of the caption and there
were people like like day by day
iterating on this concept
and the first thing that came out i
think that was like pretty good was this
notebook the big sleep and it got shared
around like thousands and thousands of
times on twitter and forked a lot and
stuff like that and so i think it used
big gan is that is that right gun and
clip
began and clip yeah and um
just that that method of like directly
optimizing the input and so now
in 2022 we probably have
we maybe would still use clip but
probably would use something that works
a little better than big gan and one of
these other methods for actually
generating the image itself
but even just a few weeks after clip
came out like you said it started this
whole like
craze on twitter of people working on
this and this was like the first the
first thing that really worked okay
and this so this is by people wonder
this is by ryan murdock who was one of
one of certainly the defining people in
the early days of uh of these clip plus
x models
um also interesting here is the the
style clip i didn't i didn't even know
oh yeah i think i think i saw this
somewhere but um so people would try to
use take a style gan
and combine it with clip and of just of
the nature big gan was sort of trained
on imagenet and larger data sets to
produce various different like a variety
of images while the style guns would
always be kind of constrained to single
data sets so it's natural to see that um
you cannot get the style gans to to do
as crazy things but it's still pretty
crazy what you can get them to do simply
by mucking around essentially with their
latent spaces
yeah that's that's a really good point
that was something that i wanted to
mention was some people have this theory
that one of the reasons why we have this
open-ended generation tool that we
didn't have before is because the new
models were trained on just like
all this data from the web that's just
from all over like a much more rich
diverse data set instead of just you
know the 1000 classes from imagenet
um yeah i mean
it
it is reasonable it's probably a
combination of data set and models and
technique but certainly the the data
place plays it and scale and scale
obviously
uh yeah so then a new after after the
gans a new contender let's say uh got
got
released which people i remember were
pretty fond of which was the guided
diffusion the clip guided diffusion and
the pictures of that were also very
impressive so what was what is the
difference between a gan and a diffusion
model as an artist
well they both do kind of the same the
same thing in the end which is that they
they produce realistic images given a
caption
but it really was important because
these this class of models called
diffusion models just kind of upset gans
in the race for
highest you know image generation
fidelity and that that was just
coincidentally by other people at open
ai during last year but these
these became like the most powerful
powerful models that we had for
generating images
but i i might have conflated two things
in the in the caption for this section
yeah these are fusion models diffusion
models no
yeah these are just diffusion models and
then the process of
generating images from a caption
one of the ways to do it with diffusion
models is what people call like guided
diffusion and you'll find all sorts of
collab notebooks floating around that
are
helping you generate images using guided
diffusion and so just
diffusion models they do work by um they
themselves are an iterative process of
producing an image so they are usually
trained by taking real images and
applying noise over and over and over
again
so in a stepwise fashion you destroy the
image and then you train a neural
network to revert each one of those
steps so to make a little less noisy
image from a more noisy image and
through some
proper through some asymptotic
properties you can essentially show that
after after destroying an image with so
much noise it is a defined distribution
and from that you can calculate some
bounds and um
then essentially you can revert the
whole process using that trained neural
network and
so we're layering iterative processes on
top of iterative processes if we're
doing uh clip guided diffusion but it's
fun
um and it makes for a very uh
entertaining image generation
it's very satisfying kind of watching
the thing emerge from a blur of noise
over some time but also it's it's a
problem because it it makes the process
take a very long time and people yeah
people i guess quickly figured out is
that you can just wait for a long time
and your quality will get better and
better to the point where it could take
hours to produce an image like this
yeah and you get diminishing returns so
it's hard to determine where to stop
especially if it's the artistic process
you know that we're talking about
so in gpt 3 it was pretty quickly clear
that there is something like prompt
engineering
or even prompt hacking that by prompting
the model in a certain way you could get
certain very defined results and people
have caught on to this thing in
these models as well interestingly with
something that's called the unreal
engine trick do you want to elaborate
what this was
yeah yeah this is one of my favorite
parts of the whole thing um and relates
back to what my my research group works
on and all the nlp stuff that people are
talking about right now
um
i i added this section mostly because of
just this whole idea of prompt
engineering like really applies to the
art generation in this case
there was a buzz online where people
were showing that
if you type in in this case maybe the
angel of air which i i should have done
for the blog post it might generate
something like somewhat interesting but
maybe not that specific or realistic but
if you add if you append unreal engine
to the prompt
it'll like there's a lot of there's a
lot of training data that's generated by
this unreal engine thing that includes
that in the caption so clip is smart
enough to know what unreal engine looks
like and if you add that into the prompt
it tends to generate images that that
look way better
and
i i don't know this is a specific style
so maybe it's not for everyone but just
the idea of like
asking the model for what you want like
if you if you type in a prompt and
generate an image but you think it's too
blurry like type not blurry or yeah
or that was the most insane thing is
like oh yeah just touch not blurry it's
like
yeah and it works or or just people just
type like beautiful yeah and it tends to
just make the art look better and we've
we've sort of stacked on this like
people right now they they like
write you know uh
pipe and then they write i don't even i
don't even know like these art sides vfx
and uh scene on art station and things
like this and you have the example here
of you just append hashtag pixel art uh
and it will give you pixel art
yeah if i'm trying to generate anything
realistic i usually put hd 4k at the end
just just because
and yeah so
there you have a bunch of these you have
a bunch of these things right here these
go more back into the the style transfer
type of thing like we give it a certain
style but i think it's important to note
that it really goes as far as just
typing like not blurry and then you get
something that's not blurry which is is
crazy but also these right here the like
german expressionism
yeah the this specific post is really
cool um this person
just went through
a few dozen artists and generated kind
of like the same images use the same
prompts but appended the names of
different artists to the prompt and they
they looked totally different i did
something like this myself that i was
tweeting about which was just typing in
names of national parks and then
generating them but images of them in an
impressionist style and it also worked
worked really well and it's a good way
to kind of showcase what clip can do
because it's yeah this is the same that
we saw at the beginning right here right
this is this is
uh
cow loon city in the style of wes
anderson
yeah that's that's the thing that
excites me the most about all of this is
the integration of like world knowledge
into the image generation process like
to generate this image the model has to
know what kowloon city looks like
and at least sort of the style of a wes
anderson film and this is obviously like
nothing that you can that you can find
online there's another one that's oh
yeah this this one on the right here can
you click on that one
it's just cookies made out of kimchi i
don't know if you could ever actually
cook them to look like this but this is
probably the best one i have in terms of
just showing off like the the use of
real world knowledge and the image
generation process these are really
awesome and the the prompt was can you
imagine how cool it'd be to have some
delicious kimchi cookies right now
question mark it's also really
interesting right that you prompt you're
really prompt by by using language now
not it's not just keywords it's actual
language
yeah that's something i'm trying to
improve upon as well like i if i were
trying to do this i probably would have
just typed in kimchi cookies
and that doesn't always tend to give you
the best outputs
and yeah i mean it's it's interesting
and i think
this as i said this is the first time
where probably research lags behind
uh the the art production in this case i
think it will be very interesting uh to
pick all of this up and sort of explain
all of these phenomena like why do
certain things work better why does it
work better if we you know have a whole
story about can you imagine and and
stuff rather than keywords uh super
interesting can we mention this one
person that's up here catherine kraussen
yes or twitter at rivers have wings
she's if you had to pinpoint one person
that's kind of the nexus of this whole
movement it's it's probably her she's
she's done so much um the data set that
i mentioned
she helped lead people to collect that
she trains all these different models
that are that are useful she helped come
up with this new metric that helps guide
the art generation process to be better
she's
wrapped almost everything up in a collab
notebook and released all these collab
notebooks that are useful for people
and i i guess she she was the first
person to combine like diffusion models
with clip guidance which is why i
referenced her here but she's done all
sorts of really really awesome stuff
yes this is definitely a known name in
the in the community
um
then you you mentioned this glide model
right here uh what what makes this
different from what came before
they directly trained a model to
generate images instead of like
using only clip and a model that was
separately trained to generate images
and they just
scaled it up pretty pretty far and
and generated some pretty cool stuff i
think that
the paper didn't do anything new
necessarily they also did
they used a lot of different techniques
from twitter but but they cited them all
um they actually cited tweets in their
paper which i've never seen before it's
very cool it's a weird world
yeah yeah
um
and maybe a collab notebook or maybe
they cited a tweet to a co-lab notebook
can't remember which
and these examples are are from the
glide model so it's it's basically just
trained to optimize
the same thing that we're talking about
already which is like the glide model
does both the the role of the artist and
the critic at the same time
and yeah you can you can given that it's
a diffusion model you can do a lot of
different things from it such as
conditional generation only generate
parts of the image uh and so on so that
was that's also very very neat property
of these diffusion models uh only
changing yeah or only like changing the
the
particular parts of the room
all right so the top right one is
is so
so so the green mask is
the area that's actually allowed to be
optimized i think this this task is
called like image in painting
it's kind of just like post text guided
post hoc image editing and
is it possible for you to like zoom in
on the top right image so
the the mask is is over the dog so the
optimization process is only editing the
pixels that are within that green mask
and this is a famous painting that has
like a king charles spaniel and then
they just type the girl hugging a corgi
on the pedestal and then optimized it
until the glide model thought that the
painting matched that caption as best as
possible and it pretty much just like
realistically substituted the
spaniel for the corgi which is so
awesome and i i guarantee you this will
make its way into photoshop yes
yeah i just thought of saying this like
this is gonna be can you imagine just
having this just painting a bit of a
mask typing in a piece of text and then
uh out comes what you want this is going
to
i think yeah i think it's it's going to
revolutionize
uh maybe not art itself but certainly
the way we interact with with pictures
as such crazy at least clip art
generation it would be nice every time
you make a set of slides to just
generate some unique little art pieces
for your slides
yes um so we've we've reached the
conclusion of your article right here
but the story is not over as we said
things are coming out almost every day
and one of the interesting things that
has come out in the last i think weeks
or months
is
this transition also into video content
and specifically there is this um
there is this technique called disco
diffusion do you know that
yeah
what is that disco diffusion is is well
it's actually the name of a of a collab
notebook so maybe if you type disco
diffusion collapse oh i actually have a
link to it at the bottom of my article i
think okay okay
but
there there are different people trying
to use these techniques to generate
videos um i think the most common well
probably the most common so disco isn't
video itself disco but you can then make
a video of it or
yeah disco diffusion is is just the name
of a collab notebook that
generates images from prompts but it
includes i in some versions tools for
kind of like interpolating through the
latent space from one prompt to another
and so the
the video is like
taking i i think a linear path from
the
image produced the latent space
representation of the image for one
prompt to the latent representation of
an image for another prompt and it
it tends to produce like these crazy
videos but it's totally continuous
because you're taking like a
like a continuous path through the
latent space so very very cool
insane
yeah this is a bit how i i don't know if
you've seen this but i've made this
music video and i did kind of the same
thing and but obviously much more
primitive these things are
these things are crazy uh in how good
they are there are a number of twitter
accounts that people can follow and i
think you link a lot of them in at the
end of your article and you also link a
lot of the uh of the notebooks of the
collabs that do this now also in recent
times i've observed at the beginning
i've observed i could find most of the
collabs people would just kind of post
them on twitter um
then
there was some collabs where it was like
you know you have to be like my my
patreon in order to get the newest
collab which i i thought it was what you
know
that's obviously cool because there's a
lot of work going into them but recently
i found is it
people want to sell nfts of their stuff
and that's why they don't give out the
collabs anymore or what's happened like
i've had a lot of trouble finding stuff
uh recently
yeah
i'm not sure about the connection
between the nft generation and collab
but that is a big source of the
excitement for this kind of thing i kind
of stayed away from that for my article
i think i might have one
example of an art piece that i thought
was particularly
compelling that was minted as an nft but
there are there are
various collections that are kind of
like this where it's like
you just you click the mint button and a
new piece of art is created and it's an
nft and it uses these techniques behind
the scenes and i think catherine crousen
has her own line of nfts
if if i were someone who purchased nfts
i would probably buy one of hers
it's just it's just
but it's just weird or is is this a
wrong impression of me that the collabs
have become harder that people aren't
sharing as much anymore
oh definitely and everyone seems to have
their own post-processing steps
i haven't really talked about that but
most of the stuff that i share is
directly generated through the clip
guided diffusion process or something
like it but
a lot of like the really good especially
really high definition art has all sorts
of steps besides just the
art generation like they might up sample
or upscale it using another gan or use
another gan that takes art and produces
new art that's supposed to be better
than the first part that it saw and plus
all sorts of regular you know photo post
processing like changing the saturation
or editing
all the different things you might edit
so just just a note to myself editing
later uh that we we're gonna have to
censor this one
just
just saying
there are body parts in that one that
are not okay for youtube
good call i probably would have would
have found you for that
um yeah sorry sorry uh intro oh yeah so
so people have their own kind of like
personal stacks for art generation
usually starting with some kind of
art artist critic thing that outputs an
image but then they do all sorts of
stuff to it after and people can be
pretty hesitant to share i think their
personal art generation processes
yeah it's it's interesting because at
the beginning you could really feel it
was more like a
community together tries to figure out
what's the best thing to produce art and
now that it kind of is
uh
and it's almost an established field
right it's more about it's more about
you know i have my little secret thing
and i can you know produce uh very cool
things and i don't want anyone else to
be able to do that and
it's interesting do you do you've also
uh we we talked about there being and
i've pulled this up right here this was
the first ai generated portrait ever
sold at an auction and it was sold by
she's a giant amount of money
um
is this a thing still like are these
things you said there's like an nft
collection is this a big market ai
generated art
well
our art is very subjective and i think a
lot of the times uh
the a lot of the value comes from who
created the art and i think in this case
it was like a pretty well-known group of
artists that generated art with
computers and they made a piece that was
generated with ai
i'm not sure
if
maybe your concrete question was
something like has anyone sold a
physical painting like this that's been
generated with clip and i haven't heard
of that happening i think that part of
that might be because
it's just so accessible and easy to
generate this type of art right now it
kind of
cheapens it
in as a commodity and uh
i i don't know i'd be interested to see
like what what are the
the most valuable pieces of artwork that
have been generated with clip
we could probably look that up in terms
of nfts but it might not correlate that
well with you know
artistic value
where do you see this going in the in
the future like um
right now i can type in yeah a bit of
piece of text and so on are the future
artists more gonna be
computer scientists that figure out
better post processing and so on or how
can this really help i i feel
it i feel that this is still
not enough controllability for an artist
to type in a piece of text and see what
comes out i feel that the artists they
still don't really actually think that
they're in control of what's happening
or that this is just a tool
where do you see this going in the
future uh especially in terms of in
terms of you know how it interacts with
art and artists
yeah it's a really exciting time
and you know it's impossible to predict
the future
i feel like
we can definitely agree that something
very important exists now that did not
exist before
um it's hard to say like what kinds of
innovations that'll directly lead to i i
agree the the prompting process is
pretty cumbersome i mean the images are
are too slow to generate
and uh you can you can type something in
the prompt and you won't always see it
in the output which is which is a big
problem i think that the people that
that share art on twitter generally have
some sort of process that resembles the
art breeder thing we looked at
where that would be something like you
type in a prompt
and then
instead of just generating one output
you generate
4 or
64.
and then you pick the one that's most
interesting to you and work with that
either like generating things that are
similar to it or just upscaling it and
and choosing like higher resolution
versions that you like better i think um
kathryn krausen has shared some like art
exploration she does where she generates
like this
maybe 32 by 32 matrix of images that all
that all fit a prompt and i think that's
really really compelling too just to
show how how cheap that this makes the
art generation process like she'll type
something in and and they'll all look
you know pretty decent which is which is
crazy
so so i think people will definitely
not just be
typing something in and producing a
single piece of artwork i can probably
guarantee that yeah but maybe the
mechanical aspect of producing art sort
of the the going and and modifying the
either pixels or or yeah brush strokes
themselves or maybe a little bit more
receding and maybe the sort of coming up
interacting with these models in some
way or selecting things that one likes
uh or maybe a bit more in the foreground
in the future
yeah yeah absolutely and maybe it'll
make art more more accessible to people
like there
there's kind of two skills maybe you
could break art down into one being
actually
mechanically creating it and the other
being like appraising it and deciding
whether it's good or not that's kind of
just like the the artist critic paradigm
but
maybe this would
enable people to create art that have a
good eye for things but
didn't have
you know the dexterity or whatever
paintbrush skills they needed to create
the art that they wanted to beforehand
that that's an exciting possibility
cool
anything else you oh wait here is elon
musk experiencing pain we gotta look at
this ah
oh that's terrible
anything else you you wanna get you
wanna
get uh anything else you'd like people
to know about this stuff
um
well i think some of the examples that i
shared were generated with the large
glide model which is not open source yet
and that is kind of a shame i think
it'll i'm sure they have good reasons
for not sharing it but hopefully within
the year or so there will be an equally
large equally capable model
because
glide is significant because it
the i think that the generations from
glide will be less abstract than the
ones we see now
which will be good if you just want to
type
i don't know so if you want to visualize
something that doesn't exist that the
model could create for you like in these
outputs
that that's kind of like a separate
thing that's closer to what i was saying
about clipart generation but um
that just the ones that are out right
now just don't don't work particularly
well
and you could still get abstract stuff
by typing abstract stuff like here like
a surrealist stream like oil painting
yeah that's a good one
um
yeah but i think the rest of the stuff
is open source so if anyone pulls up my
blog post after watching this i
encourage you to just scroll down to the
collab part and open one of them up and
try try running it it's free
yeah and there's a there's a lot of
there's a lot of references and links to
all kinds of stuff here so i definitely
invite people to check out the the blog
post again it's called the weird and
wonderful world of ai art and i'll
certainly
link to it in the description of this
video
all right jack morris thank you very
much for being with us and explaining
this to us
yeah thanks for having me
cool
[Music]
you